im zentrum von mali trainiert die
speerspitze des österreichischen
bundesheeres das jagt kommando die
malische streitkräfte derzeit bilden die
soldaten des jagdkommandos circa 150
malische soldaten aus die in naher
zukunft in den einsatz vorlegen sollen
für den kommandanten vor ort ist der
auftrag klar ziel ist es die malischen
streitkräfte so zu trainieren dass sie
in weiterer folge lokale und
grenzübergreifende konflikte
selbstständig zumindest eindämmen können
wir setzen dabei einiges an wissen
voraus betonen aber fortlaufend die
wichtigkeit der eigensicherung und der
versorgung von verwundeten
die inhalte des trainings als wir hier
im bereich zentrale durchführen sie
beinhalten vor allem die ausbildung an
allen waffen der malische streitkräfte
und die versorgung von verwundeten der
umgang mit improvisierten sprengmitteln
und mit schwergewicht natürlich die
gruppen und die zugs ausbildung
aufgrund der schlechten sicherheitslage
in der sahel zone werden wichtige
updates in echtzeit digital verteilt und
abgerufen sämtliche tätigkeiten finden
nur unter vorheriger erkundung und
absicherung stadt an oberster stelle
steht für uns die eigene sicherheit dies
wird durch die zusammenarbeit mit
animationen aber vor allem durch unsere
eigenen fähigkeiten gewährleistet diese
fähigkeiten die eigensicherung finden
sich in jedem hier eingesetzten ja
kommando team wieder insbesondere im
bereich der verwundeten versorgung der
weitreichenden waffenwirkung des
aufspüren und vernichten von
improvisierten kampfmitteln und der
kommunikation zwischen allen teilen
und um diese fähigkeiten und
fertigkeiten stetig zu verbessern
trainieren die teams auch regelmäßig
trainieren wir
dieses training ist für die soldaten des
jagdkommandos auch in extremen
gefahrensituationen und unter widrigsten
äußeren einflüssen notwendig um stets
für den ernstfall vorbereitet zu sein
trainieren und ausbilden kann man vieles
ob entscheidend für den erfolg ist der
wille